[Music]
dude are you guys getting so many
[ __ ] robo calls and spam [ __ ] i am i
get like 300.
i get robo comments i get robo pictures
hot chicks feet from hot chicks i don't
believe them dude what's the dm use of
these photos they do whatsapp a lot of
chinese whatsapp girls try to meet me
for golf dude i get a bunch of people
who who think my name is andrea and
they're like or or is this andrea and
they're like um we're supposed to have a
business meeting and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is it it's like a hot chinese girl
yeah they're always hot they got pretty
creative man what's going on with this
you know about this pandemic yeah dude
so there's there's i mean we're getting
killed with robocalls responding to them
is really funny the type of messages i
got tired of one but i should have
continued to love there were more spam
calls last month than any of the
previous six months ever why uh dude
dumber people man is it really working
is that why they're like conning a lot
of us gotta be i mean think about all
the scams you watch the scammer payback
we both watch that yep and they're
always seeing because they'll track
somebody and like try to save this one
person and they'll see like a [ __ ] ton
of other packages there which which
means that people are going to the store
buying a [ __ ] best buy gift card or
whatever putting it into a package
sending it to the irs and like pacoima
and then
that's where the headquarters is that's
what i think my bad
and then they'll
drive to some private address that
basically the the cats all got an airbnb
and then they get some girl that they
hired from like craigslist to pick up
packages yeah and that's how they that's
how they scam you and so then they take
your your card and they use it to buy
[ __ ] and then they sell that [ __ ]
[ __ ] wild right but um so it's
working that's the biggest they wouldn't
be investing effort in it without yields
yeah uh it's extremely easy to deploy
these spam texts as well an enormous
volume and also hide your identity at
the same time says the assistant
director of the ftc
uh
there are there's also a large number of
actors all over the world that's trying
to squeeze spam into the network from an
almost infinite number of entry points
all the time like all the different apps
whatsapp like you you have telegram you
have discord like glitter yes sir it's
it's everywhere right now so like i get
feet pics from from random things i get
like it's like it says like pussy.ox
and [ __ ] well that one's real that one's
right that's a really good one look hi
jack how have you been
chinese girl that all the time that's my
whole what's up dude i have deleted the
craziest one that i heard so far is uh
geo got this call and then it's like
this girl crying
and then she's like this is like andre
or something like i'm your cousin in
mexico and i've been kidnapped he goes
you don't know me but i know whatever
and you just hear it on the phone it
sounds intense but we know it's fake but
i could just imagine like imagine like
if gio's mom got it or someone that's
like
not in tune with technology
who who are we related to you just hear
slaps in the background just crying even
more and we're like what the [ __ ]
they're like good acting pretty good
it's pretty good it's just like hella
real like somebody's actually [ __ ]
yeah
or they just called the wrong number
that kidnapping is real but you're like
shut up scammer and then you hang up and
you're like really going through an
event right now yeah
it's the drug cartel that's a funny
thing too because some like my parents i
thought they would be falling for [ __ ]
like that but they're a different kind
of like old asian where they just think
everything is a scam oh so like
they've thrown away like some of my like
tax papers or like i'll get it i'll get
a red light this is a scum
okay
got a red light ticket sent to their
house and then they just threw it away
that's great
honestly good for them i just think
everything's just good it's better that
than the other thing oh yeah it is yeah
then i i pay for it so
it's all good i got one right here that
says like is this
is this
miss alicia not sure if i remember the
wrong number but [ __ ] like that and then
somebody goes oh it's not her but i'm
very alone alone yeah my kids moved out
and i need someone to talk to how long
have you guys pursued the conversation
because i know ryan is pretty notorious
for that but it's you know what it's so
often now that it's not even fun anymore
so it used to be cool because it would
happen every blue moon but now it's like
even trying to buy or sell things on
offer up those are there too my favorite
reply that i still haven't got a
rebuttal for is oh let me talk to you
after i finish coming in my mouth
and then no one replies after him or
like delete my number and stop texting
or or i'll send you somebody else's dick
pics oh that's good that's a funnel just
because typing out dick and sending that
to somebody like i never really get to
do that that much it's really fun why
don't you just start sending dick pics
to people that message you yeah well
that could be scary if
if if they're legit that's why i say
somebody else's just in case i still
want to send them mine because i'm weird
like that
like your mom just got a new number and
then she'd be like hey
and you're
people will hit me up all the time as
like
like are you a fitness trainer question
my question mark or they'll be like hey
i'm i'm i'm gonna i'm looking for a
fitness instructor and i'm well
clients dude no no these aren't they're
your clients
why would they know that
hey hey nick dunn i saw your business
and i'd be like scam yeah right i throw
my phone away dude send it to you no but
there's some where they go like oh i
have three children i'm looking for a
fitness trainer um i don't live in the
area but a driver will send uh my kids
to you and i'll be like okay cool well
how how much would they ask me how much
and i say like 10 000 and they go sweet
sounds great
call me on google voice like that's the
game so it's like a whole [ __ ] thing
and they want you to call on google
voice super weird you know you know
what's amazing is i feel like
there's so many of these people doing it
and they're so consistent
why the [ __ ] are they not just social
media managers oh they would be the best
they would be that same amount of effort
that same amount of algorithm gaming
they'll kill it and then you hire other
people to do social media they just oh
sorry i forgot
people who buy billboards even it's like
dude you're [ __ ] bro you're buying a
billboard right now you're [ __ ] i'm
gonna try to flip them next time to hit
me up you want to be my social media
manager that's a lot you want to work
with your guide
like sure google voice you're like [ __ ]
they're going to get me somehow because
i think they were real clients and i
would hit them up and they would just
send me the run around and i'd be like
oh these [ __ ] they're trying to
get me so then i would say fifty
thousand dollars for a month of training
they'd be like sounds great let's do it
that's what they would do every single
time i like to make their day a little
bit and so like as soon as they hit me
up this is like before i got beaten down
like you did by so many of them but i
used to be like uh they'd be like hi
is this whoever and i'm like no but i'm
i'm alone and i don't know anybody will
you be my girlfriend i have a lot of
bitcoin they go oh my god did i
look we got a motherboard
one of my favorite things to do is watch
these uh hackers
catch scammers that is so it is and it's
so next level like back then it used to
be like where they would just control
like you know their computer or whatever
but now what they'll do is they'll
record their whole entire operation
whole office they would get drones out
there get a outside shot everything and
they would just play this while the
scammers are like working and they're
like what the [ __ ] and then they're all
freaking out turning off all the cameras
and [ __ ] it almost seems like they're
mildly prepared for that now because if
you watch some of the newer ones yeah
but if you watch some of the newer ones
it's almost like they yell out a
protocol when they find out they have a
hacker have you noticed that no they'd
be like it was like saying subtitles oh
we got a hacker we got a hacker as if
like everyone knows what to do now oh
that's like when a us embassy has to
like immediately flee a country so they
burn all the documents and start [ __ ]
loading up because as much as i thought
like you know how like we're kind of
raised to think like oh like all these
these indian hackers whatever and you
just think like india is complicit
they're actually not they hate that [ __ ]
too
so like when these guys get in trouble
it's their own cities or their own
government to actually do raids
and they're just like get the [ __ ] out
like they don't want that either you
know what i mean
well they could be a little more
proactive in my opinion
i uh
it's pretty pervasive
uh so who their
spam emails rose by 30 from 2020 to 2021
and then like i said last month was
bigger than ever
um the federal communications commission
saw a 146 percent increase in the number
of complaints about unwanted text
messages in 2020 and americans reported
losing 131 million dollars to fraud
schemes in 2021 alone
131 million dollars yeah dude that's a
50
year-over-year jump from 2020. wow huge
industry huh
and people feel like the uh the fcc
isn't really doing anything because they
remember they don't do [ __ ] though yeah
they did that um do not call list that's
all [ __ ] now nobody believes in that
anymore i mean having scam likely
appeared in your phone made a big
difference cam like that was nice that
was that was great like google what they
do now they're i think they're
advertising their phone service and
their whole pitch is like no more scam
calls so they have an algorithm i'm sure
they have their own google voice
i thought they're hitting you up on
google voice shut up dude
google voice date they don't have any
scams we got it we got to get our brand
deals
they don't have any scams
that's what they're advertising and i've
seen the ads for it wow on google voice
i wonder if that's the guys that hit me
up i noticed i got way less since i
started using expressvpn if you use code
stephen it's pretty good
but seriously i'll buy it if that's old
have you guys been ever uh scammed for
anything like have you been caught like
ah got me [ __ ] no no i haven't
oh one time there was um there was this
[ __ ] i probably told the story before
but there was this chick who got chick
right but i was working at a high rise
downtown and i was looking for a renter
for my spot because my buddy was moving
out and with his girlfriend so i was
like okay i need a renter so i put my
[ __ ] all over craigslist and all those
places and stuff and this person's like
hey i'm going to send you a check for
five thousand dollars and they sent it
to my place
and then i was supposed to take that
money
deposit in my bank account and then go
to western union and send them a [ __ ]
check so they're basically just stealing
from my bank account yeah because
they're gonna your check's gonna bounce
right and check's gonna balance but i
already already wired that that transfer
to
already took it out into western union
sent to those cats and then you can't
get it back once it wasn't just western
union so you deposited it i didn't do
any of that [ __ ] i just i they sent me
the check and i was like yeah [ __ ]
you'll never do this in my life but that
was and i told the bank and stuff but
that was that was the closest thing
because i actually got a physical check
with this person i wonder what would
happen if you deposit that check i think
i would have probably haven't paid the
fee for the balance i had to pay the
amounts yeah the bounce fee that's it
you pay the fee when it bounces yeah you
pay the fee because you're
inconveniencing your bank but how would
you know it's going to bounce because
this fucker's a bouncer dude i i lied
actually i do get scammed sometimes when
you order [ __ ] on ebay or amazon and you
don't know it's coming from china
and like i'll order like a motorcycle
helmet and it'll be like a child's
[ __ ]
bike helmet dude that's how i got
scammed on [ __ ] instagram dude i saw
this [ __ ] paddle boat right like you
know those paddle boards and then i was
like oh this [ __ ] sick man for 30
bucks hell yeah dude i can't believe
this and i bought it and i'm like [ __ ]
and then i was like man why is it 30
dollars though that doesn't make any
sense and i was like
normally they sold me a [ __ ] paddle
for 30 bucks oh it was a piece of [ __ ]
paddle it's the same paddle that you get
on all those inflatable kid [ __ ]
boats dude yeah but let's be real what
are you gonna do with the paddle you
[ __ ] we're gonna go you're just gonna
use it as a prop on jk news
i was gonna go to the beach but then
i should have known because all the
comments were like it's for the paddles
it's for the palace with the [ __ ]
boat right and then
immediately i emailed back and i was
like
hey i need this right refund i already
requested for it and they're like it's
already shipped out i'm like how i just
ordered it 30 minutes ago there's no
[ __ ] way you shipped it out that's
what the they're really fast though
that's how fast we are that's what the
weird loophole is is that like like the
last helmet i ordered and that happened
to me
it said it would be coming from like
louisiana or some [ __ ] but then they do
like a mirror address where it's like
yeah that's where they're sent it from
but then your shipment gets delayed and
you're like oh why is it taking 20 days
and then soon it'll be like oh it's on
the way from whatever china city and
then it'll take one day longer than the
30 day money back guarantee oh so by the
time you realize it's not the right
helmet you go online and then you're
like hey uh hey ebay this happened to me
they scammed me it'll go oh the the time
is up for you to get your money back
what a bunch of jerks do you guys ever
think about
how much money or how many people would
have been scammed as much if xbox never
named it the xbox because all the people
who try to buy xbox on ebay and they get
the box notorious scam such a good scam
they just get the box just get the box
and because it's named xbox it's like i
got the xbox i guess [ __ ] it's fired up
were people getting away with that [ __ ]
because it's because it's not illegal
you're saying oh it's the xbox box oh my
god
so it's just your misunderstanding you
know we gotta get some xboxes dude and
they were real xbox boxes that's it it
was a reputable business yeah we sell
xbox
[Music]
[Music]
you